don't touch what is it it's vintage
Wendell and wild is a welcome return to
stop motion filmmaking from Creator
Henry Selleck this spooky Adventure
lives up to the hype how do they do it
what goes into making a full-length
stop-motion film like Wendell and wild
why use stop motion and not just
computer animation stick around to find
out you've never seen this before number
one Sound the Alarm during filming there
were several major delays from various
world events including the studio almost
burning down Henry Selleck describes
some of their challenges we had covid we
had the pandemic show up and we couldn't
all work at home because we have to have
stages and lights and with live action
we have to be there but that's not all
zelik explained two summers ago we had
forest fires come so close we had to
evacuate all the puppets from the studio
and this movie needed puppets the worry
was real selik emphasized we need the
puppets because they're very valuable
and hard to make and they take a lot of
time so we rescued all the puppets just
in case but the fires never quite got
there and we were able to bring them
back the key was to never give up in
Selix words we're animators we have
infinite patients number two is there a
how-to book Wendell and Wilde were
inspired by selik's kids and named by
Henry himself but artist Pablo lobato
brought their visual concept to life
selek had been a big fan of lobato and
asked the artist to create the Pablo
Picasso inspired caricatures each
Wendell and wild character has about 120
face shapes built to get a full range of
expression a team of people worked to
create each of the individual puppets
printing painting sewing costumes and
working with the internal skeletons or
armatures because of their frequent
bending and moving the puppets also
required regular repair and maintenance
over the course of the production thank
you
number three not the kind you're
thinking for the making of Wendell and
wild most of the puppets were built to
have their faces entirely replaced the
team made the puppets this way so that
animators can provide more detail in
their facial expressions while filming a
scene rather than have movable facial
features the team went with replaceable
face masks held in place by tiny magnets
the seams left on the Faces by those
masks also add to the spooky aesthetic
no thanks new name New Beginning number
four when we think of stop-motion films
we usually think of the characters
moving little by little usually we
forget about the world the story takes
place in and the backgrounds that need
to be created for the action to take
place in as far as stop-motion films go
Wendell and wild saw an unusual amount
of set building take place Creator Henry
Selleck said there was plenty of World
building especially on the Interiors the
exteriors often added backgrounds later
and what a Fantastical world it was when
watching Wendell and wild it's easy to
notice the special attention to detail
of the world particularly in how it
seems to be falling apart Selleck said
on the sets there's lots of treatments
to give them a sense of history or use
or abuse I think we took that idea
farther than maybe the other films I've
worked on number five are there any
other kind when we think of stop motion
we think of Bendy flexible puppets
painstakingly animated one small
adjustment men at a time but what keeps
the pieces of the puppet together and
how do they not fall apart after so many
bends and adjustments each of these
miniature actors actually has a very
special skeleton inside these special
skeletons are called armatures and they
are precision tools made with finely
tunable settings to suit the ergonomic
preferences of the individual
stop-motion animator working with the
puppet need to move an elbow but it's
too stiff there's an adjustment for that
need to bend an e but it won't stay in
place tighten up the setting to your
preference number six to us it seems
there is a fine line between computer
animation and stop motion and with the
power and efficiency of CGI and digital
animation what makes it worthwhile to
spend all that time animating a
character in stop motion Henry Selleck
has thought about this and seems to have
an answer to the question why do stop
motion what's the point of it he said
we've had Decades of perfect CG
animation CG the effects for live action
and a little sense of handmade becomes
fresh and new number seven world events
and other obstacles aside animating a
stop-motion film is very labor intensive
and we all want to know how long did it
take to get a few minutes of story on
film here's what Selleck said seconds we
talked in seconds it all depends on how
many characters are in the scene and how
complicated it is if it's mainly a
talking scene and not a lot of action
then those are faster and who is Behind
These seconds selik explained we usually
have one animator on a shot a shot that
could be anywhere from uh two seconds to
10 seconds long could be anywhere from
four days to two weeks it's very long
but we don't have a lot of reshoots we
have probably a 99 success rate once
we've set up the shot and we do kind of
a rough rehearsal luckily whenever they
shot it they usually did it as a one
take Wonder number eight do you dare
enter Creator Henry Selleck describes
Wendolyn Wilde's underworld setting as
some thing a little different the
underworld in the film is not the hell
it's called The Scream fair and it's
where the souls of the danged go not the
Damned but the danged the Crooked
lawyers and meter maids the bad people
but not the truly bad together selic
peel and the team created a world where
Wendell and wild are trying to cross
over into the land of the living in
order to create their own amusement park
called The Dream Fair which is a more
favorable place for the danged to go
number nine you know how they can be
Wendell and wild started as a short
story and some sketches that Henry made
years ago when his kids were very young
the kids were doing things like jumping
on Henry's new guitar which inspired him
to create the idea of Wendell and wild
because in Henry's words they were
somewhat demonic at times Wendell and
Wilde has evolved in many ways since
that day the story we see now is
co-written with Get Out director and
writer Jordan peel and you might even
say that the finished film is bewitching
number 10 the dynamic Duo Selleck was a
big fan of key and peel and reached out
to the duo to see if they could find a
project to collaborate on thinking what
the hell I'll reach out they probably
don't know who I am or anything else he
wanted to work with them it was just
about finding the right project to
invite them onto Gwendolyn Wilde was the
first project that Selleck felt inspired
to reach out for a collaboration with
the comedians as the two demon
characters Dynamic felt like a key and
peel skit number 11 time to party
Selleck met with Jordan peel and read
over the pages that he had for Wendolyn
Wilde while Henry felt like reaching out
to peel was a long shot Jordan later
said my secret that I was like a huge
fan Jordan was prompted to get more
involved and came on board as a writer
producer for the film Jordan ended up
contributing significantly to the
characters as we know them and had a
voice in shaping a number of other
details as well peel left production for
a short time to work on his film get out
and when he came back he felt he needed
to start pitching Wendell and wild
before get out released for a fear that
if the short failed it would hurt the
progress of Wendolyn Wilde fortunately
for everyone get out was a huge success
and actually ended up helping the hype
around Wendell and Wild and the best
part oh three two one are we ever glad
that slick reached out to that dynamic
duo any last words what about the
stop-motion process was most curious for
you let us know in the comments below
[Music]